Public Sénat France 24 et RFI
[Musique]
présent bonjour à tous merci de nous
rejoindre pour ici l'Europe en cette
semaine de réunion des 27 à Grenade en
Espagne pour parler élargissement du
club européen et crise migratoire sur
fond d'inquiétude sérieuse sur le
soutien des Européens à l'Ukraine ou
même au haut carabak dans le Caucase
alors nous en parlons tout de suite avec
Charles Michel le président du Conseil
européen bonjour Monsieur Michel je
rappelle que vous êtes ancien Premier
ministre belge pour les libéraux vous
êtes proche politiquement on va dire
d'Emmanuel Macron pour caricaturer un
peu peu euh commençons d'ailleurs par le
début de la semaine si vous le voulez
bien les ministres des Affaires
étrangères se sont retrouvés pour une
réunion historique à Kiev en Ukraine
visant à exprimer toute leur solidarité
avec l'Ukraine mais est-ce que le front
européen n'est pas en train de se
fissurer ils ont par exemple des raisons
de s'inquiéter peut-être de de la
l'élection d'un populiste Robert fitso
en Slovaquie les Ukrainiens qui ne
versera pas d'argent ni ne leur fournira
d'armes moi je crois que la position
deun européne est très claire nous
sommes unis pour soutenir l'Ukraine et
on va rester unis ça veut pas dire que
c'est simple ça veut pas direon doit pas
prendre en considération des
préoccupations dans les différents pays
européens mais reconnaissez que depuis 1
an et demi maintenant depuis que la
guerre a a démarré de façon régulière il
y a eu le soupçon le doute quant au fait
de savoir si on resterait déterminé dans
notre soutien et ça a été le cas on a et
on va continuer à massivement soutenir
l'Ukraine avec des moyens financiers
avec des armements avec de l'équipement
militaire avec du soutien humanitaire et
on sanctionne très durement la Russie et
il faut dire à tous les Européens que
quand on agit de cette sorte là c'est
pas simplement pour soutenir l'Ukraine
c'est aussi pour défendre notre propre
sécurité et notre propre stabilité parce
que une faiblesse de l'Union européenne
aujourd'hui donnerai le sentiment que
c'est la loi du du plus fort oui mais le
fameux Robert fitzo qui donc a remporté
les élections en Slovaquie on le disait
très populiste et surtout très proche du
fameux Victor Orban qui lui aussi sur
certains dossiers en particulier
financier bloque pour l'Ukraine vous
n'avez pas peur de vetau de ces pays
désormais qui brisent ce fameux
consensus je n'ai pas pas peur de ce de
ce risque là je suis convaincu que l'on
va devoir négocier com on le fait chaque
fois pour dégager des positions Unies et
si vous mentionnez la Hongrie par
exemple c'est vrai qu'il y a des
déclarations qui sont fait des positions
qui sont exprimées mais c'est vrai aussi
qu'il y a 11 paquets de sanctions qui
ont été décidé contre la Russie à
l'unanimité avec le soutien de la de la
Hongrie il y a eu des élections en
Slovaquie et nous devons respecter le
résultat des élections et autour de la
table du Conseil européen on prendra en
compte euh les préoccupations exprimées
par les gouvernements légitimes parce
que nous faisons confiance dans les
institutions démocratiques mais au
moment où on se parle il n'y a pas
encore de gouvernement en Slovaquie
puisqueau moment où on se parle il n'y a
pas encore une majorité parlementaire
qui soutient un gouvernement et donc il
soutient une orientation pour l'avenir
de la Slovaquie et de l'Europe est-ce
que euh les processus électoraux en
Europe ne vous semble pas euh euh un peu
fragile fragilisé notamment par des
infox Russes euh on l'a vu à l'occasion
de ces élections en Slovaquie on le voit
dans les prochaines élections du 15
octobre en Pologne est-ce qu'il y a une
grande offensive finalement pour vous
vous avez absolument raison il est
certain qu'il y a des des tentatives
venant probablement de régime
autoritaire d'essayer de fragiliser les
régimes démocratiques on a vu les
tentatives de perturbation des élections
américaines il y a quelques années déjà
probablement le brexit a aussi été
influencé par un certain nombre de
manœuvres pour tenter de manipuler les
opinions publi dans le moment de
processus électoraux et probablement il
y a la tentation d'influencer des des
moments démocratiques sur le plan
européen il y a une réponse par rapport
à cela c'est la détermination la farmeté
de tous les démocrates sur le plan
européen pour contrer ces tentative de
déstabilisation de désinformation par
exemple la communauté politique
européenne qui est cette réunion qui est
plus large que l'Union européenne un des
points que nous allons que nous allons
continuer à discuter dans les mois qui
viennent dans cette enceinte là est la
manière de mieux coopérer contre les
cyber menaces contre les cyber attaques
contre les tentatives de désinformation
mieux partager un certain nombre
d'expérience de bonnes pratiques
détecter rapidement quand il y a une
tentative de manipulation afin de
pouvoir grâce à la force de la
transparence faire la lumière et montrer
à nos citoyens ce qui est en train de se
jouer afin qu'il soi parfaitement
informé parfaitement éclairé de manière
transparente et honnête au moment ils
font des choix politiques démocratiques
Charles Michel président du conseil
européens il y avait effectivement
réunion à Grenade des 27 en fin de
semaine sur les thèmes de
l'élargissement il n'y aura pas de de
véritablement avant la fin de l'année
d'annonce officielle sur la candidature
de l'Ukraine au club européen et
vous-même avez parlé de la date de 2030
pour une entrée dans ce club je pas
parlé de 2030 pour une entrée j'ai parlé
de 2030 pour l'obligation selon moi
d'être prêt des deux côtés d'être prêt
sur le plan européen et d'être prêt dans
le chef des des États qui sont candidat
à l'adhésion alors pourquoi parce que je
pense que pendant très longtemps nous
avons procrastiné pendant très longtemps
on a fait croire au pays des Balcans
occidentaux par exemple depuis plus de
20 ans qu'ils avaient vocation à
rejoindre l'Union européenne et puis on
a trouvé beaucoup de de de raisons pour
postposer un certain nombre de de
décisions qui auraient dû être pris on
voit bien que cette guerre déclenchée
par la Russie contre l'Ukraine elle
modifie fondamentalement l'avenir de
l'Europe l' de la sécurité sur le plan
européen et on voit bien que avoir à
l'intérieur du territoire de l'Union
européenne euh les pays des Balcans
occidentaux qui constituent une enclave
et qui est l'objet de tentation et de
tentativ d'influence de la part de
forces autocratiques qui n'ont pas le
même projet que le projet européen en
terme de valeur de prospérité ou de
sécurité c'est un danger pour notre
avenir et c'est la pour laquelle on voit
bien que dans les différents pays
européens le débat a beaucoup changé
depuis cette décision de la Russie
d'envahir l'Ukraine et nous devons nous
préparer à ce débat on n' pas le droit
je le pense de procrastiner davantage
encore mais par exemple la France et
l'Allemagne
proposent effectivement que il n'y ait
moins de décision à l'unanimité et plus
de majorité qualifié afin que à plus de
30 et bien l'Europe soit gouvernable
parce que elle paraît non seulement
ingouvernable mais surtout moins soumise
au à la rigueur de l'État de droit exigé
peut-être effectivement un des points
importants c'est le processus de
décision et on do trouvé l'équilibre
entre veiller à ce que le processus
inclut tout le monde pour garantir
l'unité pour garantir quand on décide
que les décisions soient implémentées de
la même manière partout avec en même
temps cette nécessité de ne pas être
prise en otage sur l'ensemble des sujets
par l'un ou l'autre de nos pays membres
et donc je pense que c'est très
important que l'on démarre enfin ce
débat au niveau des chefs d'État et de
gouvernement pendant longtemps c'est un
débat qui a eu lieu au niveau du
Parlement qui a eu lieu dans le chef
d'observateur des sank probablement les
solutions nécessiteront de la nuance
probablement on devra conserver sur
certains sujets la nécessité d'avoir un
socle très fort de soutien avec des
consensus très forts et il y a peut-être
des idées comme ce qu'on appelle
l'abstention constructive par exemple
pour un pays la possibité de dire cette
décisionl je suis pas un grand supporter
mais je ne veux pas bloquer le processus
de décision par exemple on pour aussi
considérer que le droit de de de veto
sera à l'avenir davantage limité dans
certaines circonstances devra être
motivé par certaines situations
extrêmement particulières qui touchent
les intérêts fondamentaux d'un de nos
pays memb c'est pour dire que entre
d'une part tout à l'unanimité ou bien
demain toute à la majorité qualifiée il
y a probablement un chemin intermédiaire
plus intelligent et c'est ce débat que
nous menons avec les chefs d'État les 27
se se penchent aussi sur le fameux pacte
migratoire asile migration qui a fait de
vraies avancé pour la répartition des
réfugiés en effet entre les pays
européens sur le papier vrai avancé mais
est-ce que par exemple ça va régler le
problème de l'ampedusa et de cette crise
migratoire dans cette petite île c'est
il y a deux choses différentes d'une
part effectivement le pacte migratoire
organise plus de solidarité entre les
états-membbres c'est une bonne chose que
l'on progresse sur ce sujet-là mais je
dirais que la première priorité c'est de
veiller à ce que nos frontières soient
protégées la première priorité c'est de
veiller à ce ne soit pas les trafiquants
les criminels qui décident qui moyennant
de l'argent a le droit euh pay à ces
groupes criminels a le droit d'entrer
sur le sol de l'Union européenne et ça
c'est toute la dimension externe de la
migration pour lequel le le Conseil
européen est très très engagé nous avons
des idées claires par rapport à cela on
pense qu'il faut favoriser développer la
coopération effective entre nos services
de police nos services de justice en
partenariat avec des états-tiers pour
réellement appréhender ces groupes
criminel transfrontalier c'est un
premier point un peu comme on l'a fait
beaucoup depuis les attentats
terroristes qui ont eu lieu en Europe où
on a amélioré la coopération policière
et judiciaire mais les partenariats
stratégiques si si je peux me permettre
ne marche pas toujours très bien le le
président Tunis typiquement on cite en
exemple le pacte avec la Tunisie le
président tunisien kaais saidïd refuse
les fonds de l'Union européenne pour
l'immigrants 10 5 millions d'euros qu'il
considère comme de la charité je cite
c'est un peu mal engagé pour ces
fameuses accords bilatéraux
effectivement la manière don on engage
avec les paystiers mais pas seulement la
Tunisie la Tunisie et d'autres pays je
pense effectivement que le Conseil
européen les chefs d'État de
gouvernement majoritairement souhait
qu'il ait une approche plus globale
souhait effectivement quand on engage
avec la Tunisie on regarde aussi quels
sont les pays d'origine par la Tunisie
est principalement un pays de transit
mais il y a des pays d'origine notamment
en Afrique de l'Ouest on sait l'Afrique
de l'Ouest est confronté à des couts
d'État à des instabilités à des
insécurités qui ont un impact sur des
mouvements migratoires donc on doit
regarde de manière beaucoup plus
générale je regardais les chiffres de
migration irrégulière on voit que en un
an les migrants irréguliers venant de
pays comme le Bénin la Côte d'Ivoire le
Burkina Faso le Niger la Guinée ont cru
de manière absolument spectaculaire donc
quand on s'adresse à des coopérations
avec la Tunisie on doit aussi regarder
les interactions avec les pays d'origine
et c'est ce débat que nous avons au
Conseil européen pour veiller à ce de
manière opérationnelle on n'est pas
simplement un mémorandum avec un pays
qui serait déconnecté du regard général
si on veut être effectif une approche
globale est absolument indispensable
alors parlons quand même d'un autre
conflit aux portes de l'Europe les
dirigeants du haut cararabach ont ont
déposé les armes le 20 septembre dernier
mais presque 100000 arménien ont fuit
cette région l'allié traditionnel le
kremelin n'est plus en soutien du
président arménien
Pignan et l'Arménie est-ce qu'elle va se
rapprocher de l'Europe est-ce qu'elle a
intérêt à le faire d'ailleurs-ce que les
Européens ont réagi suffisamment bien
vous-même avez été sur le front de
négociation pendant très longtemps qui
n'ont pas forcément porter leur fruit on
a l'impression que l'Europe est absente
de ce de ce conflit premier élément
l'Europe est plus présente que jamais
dans cette région et effectivement vous
avez raison de dire que nous menons une
médiation nous ne sommes pas les seuls à
mener une médiation les Américains sont
également très engagés on coordonne
beaucoup avec eux et cette médiation a
permis de dégager des avancées
extrêmement importantes en terme
d'échange de prisonniers en terme de
mise en place de commissions conjointe
Arménie Azerbaïdjan pour discuter de la
délimination des frontières en terme de
discussion sur un traité de paix pour
normaliser les relations ou encore sur
l'avenir de la sécurité et des droits
des populations arméniennes de cette
ancienne oblaste euh du Nagorno-Karabakh
mais c'est vrai vous avez absolument
raison que cette décision unilatérale
prise par l'Azerbaïdjan de déclencher
une opération militaire nous a choqué et
nous a extrêmement déçu dès lors qu'il y
avait ces processus de médiation y
compris le processus européen qui est en
cours maintenant l'Arménie vous avez
raison euh je pense les Arméniens ont vu
de manière éclatante à quel point les
Russes avaient cyniquement trahi les
Arméniens puisque ce sont les Russes qui
étaient censés être les garants des
accords tripartites qui avaient été
conclus il y a euh 3 ans et on a vu de
quelle manière ils ont abandonné les
Arméniens et donc effectivement cet
engagement de l'Arménie de venir vers un
rapprochement avec l'Union européenne
nous réagissons de manière favorable
positive il y a quelques années déjà
l'Union européenne a mobilisé plusieurs
milliards d'euros de promesses
d'investissement pour l'Arménie pour
essayer de connecter davantage l'Arménie
sur notre réalité économique pour
favoriser les partenariats le
rapprochement avec l'Arménie je pense
qu'on doit accélérer ce processus là
néanmoins il y a eu depuis la guerre en
Ukraine la crise énergétique et pour
remplacer les importations de gaz russe
les 27 ont signé un accord gaz gazier
avec l'Azerbaïjan en février 2023
l'Union européenne a d'ailleurs augmenté
ses ses ses importations de gaz c'est
devenu la première cliente de cette
dictature est-ce que c'est un élément
qui nous empêche finalement de réclamer
des sanctions ou de d'opérer des
sanctions contre l'Azerbaïdjan il y a
deux choses différentes d'une part le
débat sur les sanctions ok on en a parlé
tout à l'heure l'unanimité des
étatsmembres donc ça c'est un un premier
point non je je ne dis pas ça je dis
simplement c'est un fait qu'il faut
l'unanimité sur un un sujet tel que
celui-là c'est un premier élément mais
pour répondre à la question parce que si
vous dites en réalité c'est est-ce que
vous n'êtes pas pris en otage pour la
dépendance partielle en tout cas au gaz
la réponse est non on n'est pas intimidé
on n'est pas impressionné par cette
réalité de de d'accord gazier on n'a pas
été lorsque les Russes ont attaqué
l'Ukraine notre main n'a pas tremblé on
a très rapidement agi pour diversifié et
nous avons effectivement aujourd'hui une
situation très différente par rapport il
y a 1 an ou il y a 2 ans on a beaucoup
beaucoup plus qu'utre fois de capacité
de diversification y compris en
regardant vers le sud de l'Europe et en
regardant vers l'autre côté de la
Méditerranée on était ensemble avec
lespil la Méditerranée à Malte il y a
quelques jours et on voit bien que notre
investissement énergétique avec cette
parti- làà euh de
l'Afrique est prometteuse pour l'avenir
ça veut donc dire que nous nous
comportons dans cette médiation avec une
grande sincérité on n'a pas d'agenda
caché l'intérêt de l'Europe c'est qu'il
y ait de la paix de la stabilité de la
sécurité et de la prospérité dans cette
région du Caucase du Sud euh notre
intérêt c'est de défendre nos valeurs
auxquelles nous croyons profondément
c'est-à-dire la dignité personnelle et
la dignité des populations arméniennes
qui vivent euh dans cette dans cette
région depuis extrêmement longtemps et
c'est pour cela que même si nous sommes
extrêmement déçus choqués et je vous le
dis et je vous le répète par cette
décision unilatérale de l'Azerbaïdjan on
ne renonce pas on nabandonne pas alors
justement puisque vous parlez de des
priorités de l'Union européenne à plus
long terme on a l'impression que les
questions environnementales sont un peu
exclues de de la liste des futures
priorités de l'Union européenne c'est ce
que dénoncent les ONG certains tout
simplement de des dirigeants en
particulier la droite le Parti populaire
européen réclame cette pause
environnementale est-ce qu'on est en
train d'enterrer le pacte vert la
réponse est non au contraire même pour
pourquoi parce que il est absolument
clair maintenant que l'Union européenne
montre le chemin à la fois en en mettant
en place cette mécanique de tarification
du carbone qui est en fait un levier
puissant pour réussir cette
transformation verte par contre il est
normal que dans le débat démocratique on
doit pas avoir peur de ce débat
démocratique il y a des discussions
parfois dures parfois int temp sur
comment on fait quells sont les mesur
que l'on met en œuvre quel est le rythme
quelles sont les priorités le 20 octobre
vous vous envolez justements vers
Washington pour rencontrer Joe Biden
pour un sommet UE États-Unis alors que
les Européens paraissent un peu tétanisé
par l'idée d'un retour l'an prochain
d'un certain Donald Trump à la Maison
Blanche qui changerait véritablement les
cartes géopolitiques une chose est sûr
c'est quel que soit l'avenir les
orientations politiques aux États-Unis
ou ailleurs dans le monde il est certain
que nous devons travailler pour
renforcer la stratégie de souveraineté
de l'Union européenne souveraineté
énergétique pour ne pas être soumis euh
à des tentatives d'intimidation le Green
Deal la transformation verte la
transformation digitale doit nous
encourager à être des leaders
technologiques et puis la sécurité la
défense pendant trop longtemps on était
pas assez nombreux à croire dans une
Europe de la sécurité de la défense et
puis on doit engager avec le reste du
monde les États-Unis sont un allié les
choses sont tout à fait claires mais
nous devons aussi engager d'autres
régions du monde l'Afrique l'Amérique
latine la Chine cher Michel merci
d'avoir été notre invité aujourd'hui
merci de cette analyse merci à vous de
nous avoir suivi vous restez sur notre
antenne tout de suite le débat continue
sur la question de la pauvreté au
Parlement européen en compagnie de
Public Sénat le débat c'est tout de
[Musique]
suite merci de nous rejoindre depuis le
Parlement européen à Bruxelles dans une
Europe qui laisse sur le carreau de plus
en plus de citoyens y compris des
enfants touchés par la pauvreté ainsi 3
européens sur 10 s'estiment précaire
selon une récente étude de l'IPSOS pour
le Secours populaire un dans un contexte
de forte inflation et de crise
énergétique les filets de sécurité de
nos social déémocratie ont un peu amorti
le choc puisque la pauvreté ne s'est pas
accrue au sein des 27 mais elle n'a pas
reculé non plus 95 millions d'Européens
sont menacés d'exclusion sociale et la
promesse faite de baisser ce chiffre de
plusieurs millions par la la Commission
européenne n'a toujours pas été tenue et
d'ailleurs lors de son discours de
rentrée la chef de l'exécutif URSA vlen
n'a pas eu un mot pour les plus démunis
à croire que l'Europe sociale n'est plus
à l'ordre du jour alors pour en débattre
deux invités un français du groupe de la
Gauche et manuel Morel bonjour et face à
vous un Roumain hein du groupe renue
Aline mituta bonjour à vous on commence
avec vous je précise que votre pays la
Roumanie est le pays le plus pauvre de
l'union avec 34 % de taux de pauvreté
vot rentré dans dans l'Union européenne
n'a pas amélioré la situation de de vos
de vos concitoyens les les plus
fragiles je dirais pas que la l'adhésion
à l'Union européenne n'a pas contribué à
augmenter la à faire la situation
meilleure mais c'est vrai que on a en
Roumanie des écarts assez importants
entre région et entre catégories
sociales on a par exemple la capitale
Bucarest et d'autres grand villes qui
sont euh au-dessus de la moyenne
européenne en ce qui concerne le PIB par
exemple mais on a d'autres régions qui
sont euh vraiment à 50 % du PIB de
l'Union européenne donc on a beaucoup à
faire c'est pour ça qu'on a des fonds
européenses pour se développer on a fait
des des effort on est passé de 38 % de
la moyenne européenne jusqu'à 70 % 70 %
donc c'est on a fait des effort mais
c'est vrai que les disparités sociales
sont encore très très très importantes
alors selon la dernière enquête hipsos
38 % des Européens sondés ne font pas
trois repas par jour et 10 % font appel
à des associations pour se nourrir alors
Emmanuel Morel c'est ça finalement le
continent le plus riche en 2023
oui mais à juste titre vous avez
souligné que madame vonlyen n'a même pas
parlé de la lutte contre la pauvreté
pourquoi parce que c'est pas son sujet
et la vérité quand même de l'Union
européenne telle qu'elle est vécue
aujourd'hui par les gens euh c'est pas
l'Europe sociale dont vous parliez qui
qui est dans les programmes et qui ne se
réalise jamais euh ce qui doit être
respecté avant tout pour les dirigeants
pour la commission c'est la concurrence
la concurrence entre les salariés la
concurrence entre les États et
d'ailleurs les traités eux-mêmes he
n'évoque pas l'Europe sociale ou la
lutte contre la pauvreté mais par contre
ils insistent bien sur la liberté de
circulation des marchandises des
capitauxx des personnes et puis ce qui
s'est passé notamment avec
l'élargissement au au pays de l'Est
c'est que plutôt d'essayer d'harmoniser
socialement les conditions de vie des
salariés européens et ben on les met en
concurrence encore plus et par exemple
c'est le travail détaché qui a fait tant
de mal dans les pays d'Europe de l'Ouest
et donc finalement moi ça m'étonne pas
qu'elle en parle pas Madame vaner lyen
mais c'est tout le problème c'est que ça
devrait être une priorité absolue et
plutôt que la concurrence et la
compétition mettre au cœur du projet
européen la solidarité ça ferait du bien
on est loin de ça et le contexte actuel
avec l'inflation avec la crise de
l'énergie exacerbe ces tension parce que
vous avez parlé des enfants et en effet
c'est très préoccupant de voir
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez des dizaines de
milliers d'enfants en Europe qui n'ont
pas de toit presque un million de sans
abri en Europe et je vous parle pas des
étudiants hein les étudiants c'est
pareil des étudiants pauvres ça explose
dans les pays européens et face à cette
situation d'urgence sociale la vérité
quand même c'est que la Commission et
bien des dirigeants ne font pas
grand-chose pourquoi parce que c'est pas
leur sujet encore une fois c'est bien le
problème àmit Touta vous faites partie
plutôt de la majorité qui soutient tient
la Commission en effet qui s'était fixé
comme objectif la réduction de la
pauvreté en Europe on l'a dit pin un mot
sur le sujet lors de son grand discours
de
rentrée de la présidente de la
Commission européenne l'Europe sociale
réduire les inégalité vous êtes d'accord
c'est pas une priorité ce n'est plus une
priorité vous êtes déçu oui bon je suis
d'accord qu qu'il faudrait faire mieux
au niveau européen sur des questions
sociales mais la vérité c'est que dans
les traités on n pas de des compétences
au niveau d'Européen sur les questions
sociales c'est une politique strictement
nationale alors pourquoi se fixer un
objectif la réduction de la pauvreté
mais justement c'est ça le problème
parce que je suis d'accord avec Monsieur
Morel qui dit on a un problème avec la
par exemple les les la pauvreté des
enfants et je viens d'un pays dans
lequel 40 plus de 40 % des des enfants
sont en risque de pauvreté d'exclusion
sociale qu'est-ce qu'on fait au niveau
européen on a adopté une
recommandation Recommandation qui dit
qu'il faudrait faire quelque chose on n'
pas de budget pour ça c'est juste des
recommandations comme ça donc on n'a pas
une vraie politique sociale au niveau
européen je suis d'accord qu'il faudrait
avoir une politique sociale mais il faut
pour cela il faut changer les traités
parce que avec les moyens qu'on a au
niveau européen dans ce moment avec le
budget qu'on a on on peut pas faire tout
donc on peut pas gérer tous les
problèmes avec S 600 milliards d'euros
par an c'est c'est vraiment ridicule le
pourqu changer les traités il y a il y a
une commission la commission elle a un
pôle emploi affaires sociales Fond
Social Européen et cetera mais qu'est-ce
qu'on fait dans la commission d'emploi
je suis membr de la commission d'emploi
on fait des recommandations comm je dis
des résolutions des des choses comme ça
on na pas le les pouvoirs dans les
traités de de faire des directives de
des règlement don de la de la
réglementation euh qui est forte parce
que sinon on peut toujours donner des
recommandations au pays mais sans avoir
les moyens de de les mettre en pratique
mais la lutte contre la pauvreté c'est
qu'une question institutionnelle c'est
qu'une question de traité là en non moi
je crois que c'est une question
politique et le problème c'est qu'il
faut changer de politique changer de
politique économique ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire rompre avec l'austérité
budgétaire là on aura un débat dans les
prochaines sessions sur est-ce est-ce
qu'on revoit le PACT budgétaire et vous
avez déjà tous les pays 10 frugo qui
disent attention surtout pas de déficit
supplémentaire en fait en Europe à part
le pape qui se soucie encore de la
pauvreté attendez bah moi et bien
d'autres nos électeurs la plupart des
gens en fait vous c'est les dirigeants
quis sont un peu sourds à ce qui se
passe mais j'insiste sur autre chose
quand je disais c'est la politique pas
seulement budgétaire la politique
monétaire par exemple aujourd'hui avec
des taux très haut bah ça a des
conséquences concrètes sur la pauvreté
hein le la crise de l'électricité quand
on voit les conséquences pour les petits
chefs d'entreprise et les gens les
ménages mais ça c'est de la politique
parce que le marché européen de
l'électricité a été conçu de façon
totalement absurde le prix est annexé
sur le gaz le gaz explose et résultat on
a des centaines de milliers
d'entreprises qui sont en difficulté
donc en en fait au-delà de la question
institutionnelle des traités la vérité
c'est que c'est la politique économique
qui est menée par les institutions
européennes qui ne va pas et c'est ça
qu'il faut changer parce que mais encore
une fois il y a pas que le PAP hein je
dire les Européens quand on les
interroge sur ce qu'ils attendent de
l'Union européenne bah ils mettre ces
questions là au cœur la solidarité sauf
que pour l'instant bah les dirigeants
sont sourds à la question du creusement
des inégalités et d'ailleurs j'insiste
parce qu'on parle de la pauvreté mais on
pourrait dire aussi qu'au même moment il
y a jamais eu autant de riches de
milliardaires et millionires dans
l'Union europé ie dire précisément pour
réagir à la crise du covid pour réagir à
la crise énergétique on a beaucoup
soutenu les entreprises on a dit qu'il
fallait de la croissance de la
croissance de la croissance est-ce qu'il
faut pas revenir vous êtes quand même
partir ru au centre de l'échiquier sur
un dogme libéral qui voudrait qu'avec la
croissance et bien on sort les gens de
la pauvreté parce que finalement on peut
avoir de la croissance et ne jamais les
sortir de la pauvreté bien sûr bah oui
c'est ça c'est ce qu'on fait en fait
avec les moyens qu'on a au niveau
européen par exemple pour le pour la
crise covid on a eu au niveau européen
le fond sû vous connaissez le fond sû
100 milliards d'euros pour aider les
compagnies pour aider les les
travailleurs à passer euh euh les les
situations qui étent euh difficile
difficile dans dans la
crise on a aussi les fonds européens on
a le Fond Social Européen 100 milliards
d'euros sur 7 ans c'est pas beaucoup
mais c'est quand même quelque chose euh
il faudrait avoir aussi la le le pouvoir
de d'adopter des règlements des des des
choses plus contraignant parce que sinon
comme j'ai dit on a la euh les
politiques par exemple pour les pour
sortir les enfants de la pauvreté mais
on n'a pas les moyens de les mettre en
place au niveau de des politiques
nationales donc ce qui reste c'est des
politiques nationaux nationales qui sont
strictement euh disons national parce
que on peut pas faire des des choses au
niveau européen et c'est c'est c'est
c'est pasrive pas à bien viser
d'ailleurs avec les les fonds de
cohésion avec les fonds finalement de
relance on on arrive à viser la couche
justement qui travaille les travailleurs
pauvres peut-être mais on arrive pas
vraiment à viser ceux qui sont déjà
marginalisés qui sont pas inscrits nulle
part qui sont un peu invisibilisé alors
déjà les travailleurs pauvres c'est 30
millions au moins 30 millions en Europe
hein et on les vise pas tous mais là où
vous avez raison c'est le programme sûr
par exemple où le plan de relance
c'était des bonnes idées le problème
c'est que les intentions actuelles de la
Commission et de certains États-membres
c'est les abandonner alors même que ça
avait quand même permis comme vous le
disiez en introduction des filets de
sécurité mais la vérité encore enc une
fois c'est qu'il faut en faire des
priorités politiques moi je crois vous
parliez de la commission emploi elle a
quand même un rôle la commission emploi
quand elle s'est saisie du sujet de
luubérisation hein des travailleurs des
plateformes elle a quand même produit du
texte moi je crois que rien n'empêche
aujourd'hui les eurodéputés évidemment
avec les autres institutions de faire
une directive sur les salaires et faire
une proposition par exemple de les
indexer sur l'inflation on sait
qu'aujourd'hui c'est quand même un Brû
sur le salaire minimum européen il y
largement insuffisante hein c'était un
premier pas mais largement insuffisante
comme d'ailleurs à Cha chaque fois qu'on
parle d'Europe sociale mais c'est
possible alors il y a quelque chose
aussi qui a changé la donne la guerre en
Ukraine et le changement climatique
accentue la notion de précarité
énergétique on a réussi à passer l'hiver
2022 2023 tant bien que mal celui qui
arrive làin c'est c'est l'hiver de de
tous les dangers d'autant plus que les
gouvernements disent ne plus avoir
d'argent pour aider les plus démunis
vous vous craigner cet hiver notamment
cette précarité énergétique qui accentue
encore plus la fragilité des plus pauvre
je dirais pas seulement la euh cela mais
il y a aussi le le problème de la des
des augmentations des prix aux aliments
et nous dans les pays de l'Est euh on on
voit on voit très bien ça euh ce qu'on
fait au niveau européen c'est par
exemple de euh donner de l'argent par
exemple par la par le biais de la
politique de cohésion pour euh
contribuer par exemple à la facture de
l'énergie mais c'est pas ça c'est pour
une période limitée donc on a fait ça
l'année passée certains pays ont le fait
je pense qu'il faudrait continuer une
politique sociale au niveau européen je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec vous mais
changeons changeons les traités alors
puis qu'on donne la la à la à l'Union
européenne les les moyens de faire ça
mais en attendant vous faites quoi pour
l'hiver qui arrive vous dites quoi au
concitoyens européens qui voit l'hiver
arriver avec des factures qui flambent
et une précarité énergétique qui cesse
de de s'accentuer mais par exemple pour
les pour le gaz pour le gaz on fait déjà
des choses par exemple on a pris une
décision au niveau européen la
Commission a a pris cette décision de
mettre dans le dépôt de gaz de gaz assez
de de gaz pour passer l'été donc c'est
c'est ce quelque chose qu'on a fait déjà
je suis d'accord qu'on qu'on devait
faire plus mais il faudrait avoir des
les moyens pour faire ça au niveau
européen parce que comme comme je disais
au niveau national c'est vrai que chaque
pays prend ses propres mesures
d'ailleurs en France Emmanuel Morel les
restosx du cœur on appelle désormais à
la solidarité de l'État alors que
d'ailleurs l'association elle était
particulièrement aidée
traditionnellement par la politique
agricole commune elle recevait he les
les résidus de de cette pâqu même la
solidarité privée semblant faillite les
les gens ne ne veulent plus aider quoi
en fait c'est plus une priorité o ils
n'ont plus les moyens je dirais pas ça
il y a surtout beaucoup de gens qui
n'ont plus les moyens d'aider les resto
du cœur en effet ont alerté c'est une
situation très dramatique mais si on en
reste à l'Europe c'est exactement pareil
c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle
on est un certain nombre d'eurodéputés
de droite comme de gauche a demandé à ce
que le fond qui va en direction des
banques alimentaire soit
largement amélioré aujourd'hui c'est 600
millions sur sur une période de 5 ans ça
ne suffit pas et en France on dit que
c'est un besoin de plus de 30 % c'est à
peu près vrai dans tous les pays
d'Europe he même des pays supposément
riches comme l'Allemagne he ou la
Belgique donc là là je pense que dès la
la la discussion budgétaire on peut on
peut améliorer ça concrètement mais je
reviens sur ce que disait mon collègue
qui vient de de Roumanie moi je pense
qu'il y a quand même des choses qu'on
peut faire maintenant hein sur les prix
alimentaires bah il faut alors c'est pas
très libéral c'est pas vraiment le
marché mais il faudra en passer par le
blocage des prix parce que aujourd'hui
en France par exemple les prix
élémentaires là c'est plus 12 % on
prévoit éventuellement plus 20 % l'année
prochaine vous voyez bien que ça c'est
une trappe à pauvreté considérable mais
je reviens sur l'énergie parce que je
trouve qu'on a pas assez le débat au
niveau européen on a un marché européen
de l'électricité qui marche sur la tête
indexer le prix sur le gaz c'est une
folie puisque par définition le gaz est
en train de s'en on est sensé le
réformer d'accord on réforme sauf que ça
fait maintenant 6 mois qu'on dit il faut
le réformer les les les les les
commissaires d'ailleurs sont pas
d'accord entre eux les États-membres non
plus or là il y a une urgence une vraie
urgence je vous prends l'exemple
français si comme les portugais ou les
Espagnols on sortait du marché européen
de l'électricité les prix pour nous ça
serait 50 % moins cher vous imaginz ce
que ça veut dire pour les gens donc là
si euh si c'est pas au cœur de la
campagne européenne par exemple et si
c'est même pas au cœur de nos débats là
dans les mois qui viennent B on joue pas
notre rôle et ben moi je veux que la
question du marché européen de
l'électricité qui dysfonctionne
totalement soit traité urgemment alors
justement vous parlez de la de la
campagne européenne les parti de
d'extrême droite argu he qu'il ne faut
accueillir aucun réfugié aucun migrant
dans une Europe qui ne parvient pas à
aider ses pauvre c'est un argument
massus c'est une réalité àa bah c'est
c'est c'est clairement une réalité je
pense dans toute l'Union européenne les
les partis deextrême droite sont euh euh
sont très très puissants et on est je
pense que dans le futur Parlement on
aura peut-être untiers de députés qui
viendront de de ces familles politiques
qui vraiment mais c'est un argument qui
qui se diffuse de plus en plus dans les
sociétés EUR qui se diffuse mais je
pense que nous les les partis politiques
les politiciens qui sont au centre euh
devons faire plus pour expliquer au aux
gens qui sont quels sont les avantages
de l'Union européne qu son l'avantage de
de la démocratie parce que l'extrême
droite je pense qu'ils sont aussi contre
la démocratie en soi et donc euh oui les
élections de de l'année 2024 sont
essentielles pour le futur de le rêve
européen il existe encore on peut
espérer une Europe sans pauvre un jour
oui mais je reviens sur votre sujet
alors ça sera la confrontation
traditionnelle avec l'extrême droite
mais le principe de solidarité qui
devrait prévaloir au sein de l'Union
européenne il doit prévaloir aussi avec
les autres pays du monde moi je
comprends pas que l'Europe fasse pas
plus d'effort pour participer au
développement de continents qui sont nos
frères je pense à l'Afrique je pense à
je pense au pourtour méditerranéen qui a
été quand même abandonné depuis quelques
années faut bien le dire il y a plus de
politique européenne en direction de la
Méditerranée bah ça ça fait partie aussi
parliez du rêve européen en tout cas
l'identité politique de l'Europe c'est
aussi ce principe de solidarité qui vaut
qui devrait valoir à l'intérieur et à
l'extérieur on en est loin mais moi je
désespère pas avec un peu plus d'impôts
peut-être pour financer ce rêve européen
mais c'est pas que les impôts c'est
surtout la redistribution des richesses
madame de Camaret parce que en fait
comme je disais tout à l'heure des
riches en Europe il y en a de plus en
plus le problème c'est c'est qu'il faut
réduire les inégalités et pour ça faut
une des politique de redistribution dont
madame ver l et sa majorité ne veulent
pas et on aura l'occasion d'en reparler
merci merci à tous les deux d'être venu
débattre sur notre plateau merci à vous
d'avoir été en notre compagnie restez
bien sûr sur nos deux antennes
l'information
continue
[Musique]